hey leute und herzlich willkommen zur
live stream zusammenfassung von dem
gestrigen stream vom donnerstag 20 uhr
bis 21 uhr acht er sollte eigentlich bis
22 uhr gehen dann allerdings zweimal
gestorben war dann auch ein bisschen
gefrustet und wollte da nicht weiter im
singleplayer weiter spielen und euch das
auch nicht zumuten weil die qualität
auch relativ schlecht war wegen im
internet nicht werthaltig stream können
bis sich ausgezogen wenn eine bessere
leitung hat mein internet ist so gut wie
die unteren zehn prozent von deutschland
das haben
das hat mir seine website gesagt wo ich
das mal getestet habe auf die
legitimität aktivität auf die seriosität
dieser website möchte jetzt nicht an
spielen
aber es ist auf jeden fall mega schlecht
und ich konnte in keiner guten qualität
streamen deswegen wahrscheinlich ganz
gut dass sie sogar im nachhinein dann
zweimal gestorben bin aber das ist jetzt
sollte sich die sache seien hier und
zwar ist das ihr die leitstelle
zusammenfassung und zwar soll man am
nächsten tag des livestreams hochladen
was man dann im livestream gemacht hat
bzw
man darf auf den server gehen und das
zeigen auch wenn man gestorben ist
meinte timm
man darf das allerdings auch einfach
dann so ein paar ausschnitt aus dem
livestream zeigen ich jetzt einfach mal
ganz kurz auf den server weil ich eh
noch was sagen will und zwar bin ich in
stream an den host dass van gaal nimmt
dieser ip ich einfach kurzes schwarzes
bild an einen see ddp nicht ich glaube
eben ganz kurz nach hause und zwar weil
ich hier auf dem server und ihr seht
schon ich habe gar keine waffen mehr
woran könnte das dann lieben also ich
bin auf den server draufgekommen und
dachte mir so ich bin relativ erträglich
weil auf dieser insel damit meinen
hunden und dann ihr könnt das übrigens
alles nachgucken auf meiner tv /
konkreter seite wenn euch das
interessiert bin dann nach hause dieses
ist eigentlich fast alles bin danach
weiter nach hause laufen bin dann hab
dann auf den weg sogar richtig wie der
mexikaner ist stelle ich jetzt einfach
mal wo ich in den schnell ich stelle
mich einfach auf mein dach eben und
genieße dann blick in die stadt müssen
durch die tür gehen
ich stelle mich einfach auf mein dach
damit wir dann schönen blick haben
auf nähe ist eigentlich noch schöner
einfach mal ganz kurz mir so ein
bisschen das wir gemütlich hier sehen
können so dass sich die schützen müssen
muss jetzt nicht schnell gehen banken
karte diese scheiß karten so kaputt so
ich komme auf den server und ich war
halt dann da und habe die ganze existenz
noch gefunden auf dem weg nach hause und
was sie technisch für gelbe zeug lang
das ist das kann dann will die ganze
existenzen gefunden wollt dann nach
hause laufen dann allerdings in eine
schlucht aufgrund eines alters liegt
derzeit hoch aufgrund eines lecks in
einem stream wofür keiner was kam das
ist einfach nur im internet will ich
dann eine stufe eingefallen was sehr
doof war dann auf einmal wurde ich halt
von ihm was getroffen und ich freue mich
natürlich woher kam das ich sehe dann
hinter einer wand steht die beta lp da
dachte ich mir so okay vielleicht wieder
nicht rollen vielleicht wenn ich einmal
boxen zu zeigen so hey guck mal ich bin
neben dir hallo herzlich willkommen da
im stream
und dann geht hält mir dachte ich mir
habe ich falsch gedacht der hat mich
dann einfach angegriffen
was natürlich legitim ist also man
brauche jetzt natürlich nicht mehr kann
das ist natürlich regelkonform dass man
angegriffen wird außerhalb der stadt ich
kann natürlich auch innerhalb der stadt
angegriffen werden
das ist natürlich komplett gleich nur es
ist halt wg team in der situation dass
ich angegriffen werde
ich dachte dann erstmal so heer der box
mich vielleicht jetzt ein paarmal box
erstmal nicht zurück vielleicht will er
sich nur so begrüßen er boxt ich dann so
ein bisschen und irgendwann euch dann
gesehen oh ich hab schon 34 leben
verloren 4 herzen verloren und wurde
langsamer 58 ich mir scheiße vielleicht
wäre ich nicht mehr so wenig wirklich
töten
der hatte das vorher standen chat
angedeutet aber ich dachte halt wirklich
der macht es nicht und er sind wir halt
wirklich noch eine begrüßung der
wirklich tollen und so aber er hat mich
dann wirklich getötet
es war sogar sechster ab ich hab dann
zurückgeschlagen und habe ihn wohl so
oft getroffen dass er nachher noch ein
halbes herz hatte
also hätte ich am anfang direkt mit
geboxt hat sich wahrscheinlich sogar den
pvp kampf gewonnen was relativ komisch
gewesen wäre war ich eigentlich wie ich
finde gar keine guten sachen hatte aber
das ist jetzt tut jetzt auch gar nichts
zur sache jedenfalls bin ich dann halt
ausgerastet weil ich nicht verstehen
konnte dass ich zehn minuten streamen
und eh schon gefrustet bin weil alle
leute meine die quali für kaka wofür ich
nichts kann
im internet jedenfalls ist es klar dass
ich mich da natürlich dann angegriffen
fühle wenn ich halt angegangen war jetzt
gerade von mir nur ich hab dann halt ein
bisschen überreagiert ich hab dann
debitor beleidigt ich habe dann gesagt
so ja wie kann man so viele ads haben
und einfach einem stimm töten was sollen
das ist man da dann irgendwie total
klick geil und so was alles weil ich
verstehe auch bis jetzt noch nicht was
es toll mich zu töten natürlich gehört
es zum spiel dazu und er kann mich
natürlich töten allerdings auf moralisch
menschlicher ebene wusste er dass ich
einen stream mache und wie gesagt auf
moralisch menschlicher ebene ist es für
mich immer noch nicht legitim dass du
tun natürlich auch juristisch
regelkonform
juristisch ist regelkonform weil es in
den regeln so steht das man halt immer
getötet werden kann von leuten aus
anderen städten nur ich finde dass das
das ist nicht so der reiz also ich fände
es zum beispiel nicht cool wenn ich
jetzt eine person töten würde die gerade
im livestream ist und vor allem bei
heroes ist so dass man da nicht weiter
stream darf ich bin dann halt vom server
gegangen er hat dann meinen grabstein
genommen hat ihn zum friedhof gebracht
das kann ich euch bei ihnen ganz kurze
zeit in der nicht mehr runter springen
welcher nichts habe ich hab ja nix so
zeigt euch das mal ganz kurz hier beim
friedhof ich laufe immer den falschen
weg zum friedhof das ist richtig gut da
hinten ist ja unser friedhof was das
hier was soll das eigentlich menge nur
jemand abbauen ich darf ja gerade nichts
machen hier so richtig dafür nichts
verändern dass der friedhof von crafter
getötet durch die bieter lp
naja ich bin laut friedrich das zweite
mal gestochen habe ich bin sechsmal
gestorben so jedenfalls war ich dann
halt tod und übrigens ich habe keine
live cam gerade fairfax kam gerade recht
einfach gültig ist nur sondern letzten
zusammenfassung machen da braucht es
keine emotionen von gesehen oder so ich
war dann tot und er hat mein grab
schnell zurück gebracht ich bin dann
gries bond und in der zwischenzeit war
habe ich ihn halt noch ein skript
geschrieben
ein bisschen beleidigt ist es auch egal
meine wortwahl
jedenfalls wollte ich mich hiermit
nochmals öffentlich dafür entschuldigen
dass ich ihn da beleidigt habe er hat
mir allerdings dann ein grabstein
zurückgebracht was schon mal ich sagen
etwa damit ich weiter stream konnte ich
habe dann auch weiter gestreamt und
wollte meine sachen zurück und erhält
als mega chillig die chance war nicht
geladen deswegen hätte ich sogar die
meisten meiner sache unglaublich wieder
bekommen außer erzählt alle aufgesammelt
er hat allerdings auch meine hunde
getötet und jacky lebt angeblich noch
laut den kommentaren im stream
ich bin irgendwo dahinten gestorben da
irgendwo da so da in die richtung da ca
koordinaten als erwartet diesen weg
koordinaten sind lacht keine ahnung
wurden allerdings sehr häufig
geschrieben ich weiß hat die koordinaten
ich hoffe nur dass als kein anderer von
den leuten wir irgendwie hingeht und mir
die sachen cloud sich schockiert über
irgendwie was wäre ein bisschen doof
jedenfalls hat er damit erzeuge machen
ich wollte ihnen sachen zurück und bin
dann nochmal dover weise gestorben was
dann allerdings um einen fehler war weil
die vitaldaten schon weg war und ich bin
einfach noch mal in die gleiche schluss
reingefallen war halt echt doof und dann
kommt michael keiner wiederbeleben und
dann bin ich irgendwie einfach so
intuitiv wie sport wie man das so macht
bin dann bist da vorne gelaufen bis dazu
den googles egal wo ich halte hier neu
geboren bin und dann bin ich halt wieder
runter gegangen weil dann halt auch
allem einen höhenausgleich weg weil ich
so fakt stimmt darf ich gar nicht wenn
man direkt runter gegangen
ich habe ja auch nichts großartiges
gemacht da derzeit durch genießbar und
bin also das war einfach intuitiv dass
du mir auch leid dass sich also ein
bisschen gegen die regeln verstoßen habe
und ja das war so der leistungsträger
danach bin ich noch kurzen single der
gegangen bis mit euch sogar über
gequatscht habe ich noch mal dafür
entschuldigt und ich bin halt einfach
wirklich in der situation wo ich getötet
wurde
ich möchte wirklich versetzt euch bitte
meine lage bevor ich jetzt hier
irgendwie beleidigt werden oder so ich
hab die ganze zeit gesagt ihr wollt euch
selbst eine meinung bilden und ich habe
auch kurzer zeit gesagt ganz kurz ja was
soll das bildet euch eure eigene meinung
aber wenn die mich hat das hoch lädt
dann was ich gesagt ja dann display das
video oder irgendwie sowas dass da
möchte ich mich halt wirklich dafür
entschuldigen ich es bringt jetzt nichts
hier 100 zu schreiben höhe bevor das zu
sagen ich weiß ich finde es ja selber
auch blöd ich kann jetzt allerdings
nichts daran ändern ich kann die zeit
nicht zurückdrehen und einfach dann
meine reaktion revidieren
beziehungsweise meine meinung und
deswegen bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig
als jetzt einfach zu sagen sorry die
vitor wenn du das hier siehst dass ich
ein bisschen überreagiert habe
allerdings finde ich sein verhalten und
das töten meinerseits immer noch total
kacke ich bleibe bei meiner meinung ich
lasse mich doch nicht von abbringen
natürlich ist es legitim und natürlich
gehört es zu einem pvp spiel dazu dass
man getötet wird aber ich finde gerade
im livestream wenn man sich zwei stunden
zeit nimmt und ich dann sage ich dir auf
kommentare ein und alles mögliche dann
finde ich halt schon ein bisschen doof
wenn man ein
tötet und ich glaube wenn ich selbst
eine andere person in der situation
töten würde würde ich mich dabei auch
nicht glücklich fühlen
und er hat ja in china so höhnisch
gelacht und alles getötet und irgendwie
weiß nicht also ich würd mich denken ich
zum abfeiern
aber das ist wie gesagt meine meinung
ernst gemacht und deswegen kann ich
jetzt auch nichts mehr dran ändern ich
kann auf meine sachen ändern was ich da
gesagt habe ich möchte hiermit nur mich
nochmal öffentlich für beide vitor dafür
entschuldigen
und ich möchte auch sagen dass ihr
einstellen sollte weil ihnen die videos
zu dislike bzw die mal zu liken seien
zeichen der entschuldigung mehr oder
weniger und es tut mir wirklich leid
dass er überreagiert habe aber es war
halt einfach in der situation ich war
halt einfach gefrustet darüber dass der
stream an sich tacke war die qualität
war behindert ich bin zweimal gestorben
und dann muss man halt einfach mit dem
frust rauslassen dass alsdorf das ist
debitor war und nicht irgendwie boxsack
in mein zimmer oder so sondern es regnet
jetzt auch gerade das ist auf jeden fall
legal
naja jedenfalls das war so die leistung
zusammenfassung ich habe halt echt keine
sachen mehr
ich habe meine triebel rüstung verloren
ich hab auch auf dem weg dahin wieder
acht existenzen gefunden glaube ich oder
paar mehr ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
weiter unter die erde damit wir das noch
weniger hören dann sogar noch lauter
hier hat man sich nicht existenten
wieder gefunden und wollte mir dann
wieder den ball aber machen aber ich
denke ich werde dann einfach als ich bin
zweimal gestorben von daher habe ich
eine upload sperre bis montag also heute
ist ja freitag das heißt samstag/sonntag
pause und am montag kommt wieder ein
video und dann wollte ich halt mega
produktiv weitermachen
eventuell kann ich auf dem peter
überreden dass wir dann zusammen
aufnehmen das ganze erklären hier
nochmal damit ihr seht dass zwischen
unterwegs ist und dann werde ich halt
mega produktiv sein und versuchen die
ganzen sachen wiederzubekommen
eventuell darf ich mir auch ein paar
sachen bei cap aus der kiste nehmen bei
broken flowers darf ich mir noch was
neben einfach an die da hab ich mir die
essenzen genommen keine ahnung mal
gucken wie ich das ganze regeln werde
ich hoffe einfach dass da
dann jetzt erst mal pur ist und dass
weiß dass man die leistung
zusammenfassung ich geh jetzt vom server
herunter wir sehen uns dann montag
wieder in der produktiven folge noch mal
kurz zusammengefasst ich bin im
livestream zweimal gestorben bin relativ
ausgerastet gegenüber debitor beleidigt
und im nachhinein mich dafür jetzt
entschuldigt gestern auf facebook wenn
ihr das video seht und jetzt auch heute
in diesem video und ich auch persönlich
bei ihm mehr kann ich jetzt gerade nicht
machen in der situation es tut mir leid
ich bleibe bei meiner meinung dass ich
finde dass ist nicht hätte sein müssen
mich umzubringen dann live stream in der
aufnahme kann man das ja gerne mal
machen weil digital 20 minuten aber wenn
ich sage ich mache zwei stunden und 18
minuten getötet ist der ganze streamwide
im eimer trotzdem entschuldigung dafür
ich hoffe ihr den sun und devito nimmt
auch an und dann würde ich sagen sie uns
montag wieder bzw wir sehen uns wieder
wenn ihr wieder ein video von nikci